hello everyone my name is reto Meier
welcome to this week in Android
development for October 1st 2012 last
week on Android developers live we
broadcast from our brand new studio
balanced a hair's breadth from the
gaping more of a formal SOI that's
written to expand and Gotha Solmaz
featureless decks each week we'll be
throwing a team member into the depths
of the void in an effort to appease a
shapeless dread overlords in Android
design in action last Tuesday Roman and
Nick took glimmer and camera zoom
effects out behind the woodshed for a
full TX makeover check out the video to
see how they fared on Thursday we
invited the camera actually patients to
be interviewed on Android developers
strike back then on Friday Ian and Dan
hosted the Friday games review watch as
Dan bravely continues the broadcaster's
by being under constant mind-control
attack from one of the voids nameless
terrors and on the applet again and I
found an innovative solution to planning
our holidays on company time by
reviewing travel planning and booking
apps as always you can find all of last
week's shows on the schedule for this
week at Google developers live that's
developers.google.com slash live Sasha
Android coming up this week catch our
Wednesday office hours live from London
Mountain View and Sydney then on
Thursday we're gonna Nick take a shot at
travel planning apps worldscope webcams
and kayak on thursdays developers strike
back we'll invite them and the other
travel booking app developer to provide
feedback on our feedback from a safe
distance of a hangout on this Fridays at
clinic we're taking a look at video
player up to their regular new time at
10:30 a.m. Pacific then later that
afternoon Dan will continue his battle
to the death with a void creature of
your choice use the moderator page link
here to nominate Dan's terrifying
opponent and the games you'd like his
co-host to review in other Android
development news after a spirited debate
over which 80s power ballad best
describes our team's feelings for the
Android development community our final
option settler near the developer
relations director Billy Rutledge's
suggestion or classic Whitney Houston
ballad I will always love you and
director of product management Hugo
barrows choice of LMFAO's sexy and I
know it but for a recording of either
could begin executive chairman Eric
Schmidt declared our devotion to
developers Gangnam style while visiting
the Google office in Korea last week
also saw the release of a new administer
collection series 3 from dead zebra
series 3 features 14 awesome blind box
designs from a variety of artists Willis
saw the launch of Google Play services a
new platform that offers Android app
integration with other Google products
such as Google+ check out the Android
developers blog to see how Google Play
services makes o or two authorization
available to
apps with good user experience and
security a recent internal debate on
improving the developer experience
concluded that we should give those
developers and badges developers loved
badges I'm happy to announce that these
new badges are now available into the
distribute tab on the Android developer
site the dog is looking to improve the
display performance of their apps can
now take advantage of the new systrace
guide that explains how to use straight
stool to collect a review code execution
data from your app and the Android
system to improve the performance of
your app in un updated apps this week
the New York Times and Workout Trainer
by skill will both released updates
starting this week I'll be interviewing
a different member of the Android
developer relations team in this week in
Android development here's the new Louis
answering the question where do you see
yourself in five years
hello everyone my name is reto Meier
well this week in Android development
that was the Anila was offering some
insight into his fondest hopes and
dreams that's all for this week in
Android development we look forward to
you joining us for our many live shows
this week and remember you don't know
you're beautiful that's what makes you
beautiful my name is reto Meier thanks
for watching